hi martin hopefully you can hear me
bye
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to our planning committee this
afternoon
which is being live streamed on youtube
before we begin i would like the
principal clark to explain the health
and safety arrangements for this meeting
thank you chair um as you can see
members were all socially distanced
within the chamber um if um you would
like to wear a mask during the course of
the meeting please do so although it is
advisable for you to remove it while
speaking that will apply as well to the
members of the public who are joining us
when you are speaking at the sneakers
table if you wish to remove your mask
you may do so um the windows are open
chair um if members find it a bit chilly
my apologies um we'll just keep the air
flowing
thank you
move on to the first item this afternoon
apologies in absence i think we've got a
full friend
we have apologies
are there any apologies alan uh yes sir
councillor armitage um is now able to
attend and he's substituted by
councillor and cliff
and councillor ridgeway has sent her
apologies with no substitute chair thank
you thank you
are there any declarations of interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and
sorry roger sorry yeah thank you chair
maybe not a declaration of interest but
i would like to uh
state for the record although i wasn't
here in december uh regarding the clay
lane application i would like it to be
noted on record that i have watched the
video that's on youtube
of the december planning meeting for
that application okay thank you
all right we'll move on to item three
minutes of the last meeting
we now have the minutes of a meeting for
tuesday the 14th of december 2021 are we
happy that they are a correct record
thank you are there a seconder thank you
all those in favour
thank you
the main business
as you can see we have five main items
to consider each of these has its own
report and i am happy that we take them
in that order
the last of these the report of section
106 agreement debt will be taken as an
exempt item
the live stream of the meeting will be
stopped at that point and any public
will be asked to leave the room
thank you
the first application this afternoon is
ned for slash 21 forward
zero zero six two seven
forward slash fl clay lane
i've got quite a bit to read out on this
so please bear with me
variation of condition to approve plans
to allow for changes to the road
alignment and plot positions some major
development at land opposite 24 to 44
clay lane play cross
now as we all know this application was
deferred at our last meeting
committee did after an extensive
discussion the purpose of the deferral
was for further information to be
obtained in order to clarify the flood
risk to the site and what impact the
proposed minor changes would have on
this
the planning officers have had a meeting
with the applicant and their agent just
before christmas
they explained the committee's concerns
and also the additional information what
had been requested
the agent produced a briefing note
following on from this meeting
this note has been circulated to members
and it has also been placed on the
council's website
i don't intend to go through the note in
detail however the bottom line is that
the applicant and agent have not
provided us with any additional
information
and they are not obliged to do so
and they do not think that it would be
necessary in order to deal with this
sort of minor application and in
fairness that is also the view of our
officers who have produced a report
which sets out the information that we
actually need to take a decision on
so what does this mean for us quite
simply there is no further information
for members to consider from what we've
had last time
consequently there is no reason why the
committee should not now consider and
determine the application
and that's what i hope we can do today
finally members i think it is important
that we all keep in mind that this is
this application for minor variations to
the road layout and plot positions
which we have been asked to consider
not the development as a whole
that's been passed so we need to stick
to the task in hand
but before we get started is there
anything that the planning and legal
officers would like to add
not at this stage
okay thank you
i would now like the club
phil do you need to say anything at this
stage
uh
no chad and the late reps were
circulated so there's nothing further to
the late reps
thank you
again i would like the clerk to explain
how we will now deal with the
application
thank you chair
this is the procedure for considering
the application today
the committee will resume from the point
where it left off on the 14th of
december
when the chair had opened the floor to
motions
a motion must be moved and seconded
before a vote is
taken if an amendment to a motion is
moved and seconded then that amendment
will be voted on first
as members will recall
a motion to agree officer
recommendations
and approve the application was put to
the committee at its december meeting
but was rejected
please note that if members now wish to
agree the original office
recommendations
then committee will first need to
suspend
council procedure rule 13.2
which prevents a motion or an amended
amendment moved within the past six
months from being moved again
at least half of the present of the
members present will have to agree to
the suspension of council rule procedure
13.2 for it to be approved by the
committee
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against the officer recommendations
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving a motion against
officer recommendations
should comprise the relevant planning
issues
and be supported by the evidence as
necessary
if a motion to reject officer
recommendations false
or in other words this is not passed
that doesn't mean that the
recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you would need to take a positive
decision through a further motion in
favor of the recommendations or another
course of action
this would need to be agreed by the
committee through another vote
thank you chair
thank you
this is the point of the meeting at
which i would normally open up the floor
for motions to determine an application
however on this occasion i think that we
should first address the issue which the
clerk has raised about the procedural
rule preventing a motion to approve
officer's recommendations from being
removed
in order to do this i'm going to propose
that we now agree to suspend council
procedure rule 13-2
do we have a secondary
thank you
we have a motion to spend council
procedures 13.2 we will not take a vote
on this by roll call
thank you chair members if you could um
clearly say fought against or abstain
counselor and clair for
councillor cooper
four casa elliott or casa foster
four council hall
four councillor hancock
four casa hearts on
four council jones
council liggett or councillor powell
four councillors
four and councillor of
four unanimous chair thank you
i would now like the clerk to inform us
of the outcome which is unanimous
now having heard and read everything
both from today and the meeting in
december what is the view of the
committee on this application i'm now
opening the floor for motions and i
propose that we move this application
i'll second that thank you
we're now asked to vote as explained
earlier body chair was that counselor
and cliff who seconds it yes thank you
thank you because they fought against
staying counselor and cliff
councillor cooper
four councillor elliott
councillor foster four
four castle powell
tesla rouse abstain
councillor ralph four
that's eight votes four one against with
three abstentions chair that's carried
thank you
thank you for that and let's move now on
to the next
second application which is ned forward
slash 21 forward slash 0 1 0 28 at
winger worth
this is
demolition of an existing building and
erection of a new house at hockley house
hockley lane wingerworth
in line with our normal practice i'm
going to ask the planning manager and
officers to tell us about any late
comments reports that have been produced
and to give a brief presentation showing
any photos and plans of the site
i will allow the offices to complete the
presentation consequently members could
please reserve any points of order or
questions about the process until the
end thank you
thank you chair
just in opening i'd like to report to
members of late representation that was
received at nine o'clock last night from
mr cole
who's objected to the application chair
on two parts
firstly that the house appears on a map
of 1758 built by the unlocks of
windworth hall the house is stone and
slate built it was then home to the
maidens and then used as a market garden
the house then left to the nhs
and chair there were also attempts to
keep hotly lane as rural as possible
when the recently completed hockey rise
development took place
with houses sent back from the lane
new house looks to be located forward
the present house
a little place with other historic
properties on hotly lane mr cole is
aware that hotly house for structural
problems
suggests that the new house is built in
the same style as hockey house
including the extensions permitted in
the site history is respected and the
developer gets his house
just on that point chair briefly the
issue of heritage and associated matters
is discussed in the officer report
and the officer view on the design of a
new house is also assessed in that
report
just in terms of the detailing chair the
application seeks consent to demolish
the existing building
and erect a new house at
the site
and
the various material matters chair are
set out in the officer report
just as a reprise of yesterday's site
visit share the application site
set out in the center of the slide here
with the hotly lane running here as
you'll see in a second the area
surrounding
constructed and built out
a number of residential properties also
referred to the report chair is this
dwelling here which sits opposite the
site
this range of agricultural buildings and
with associated uses also sitting
opposite the site the existing building
you can just make out in the center of
the hexagon there
in terms of the detailing apologies the
application site comprises the single
plot as i say the area around
it's now been constructed with new
houses properties opposite range of
agricultural buildings the dwelling
house here
this slide chest shows the application
site which is this
element of the
slide here the area around
as we saw at the site visit yesterday
is
now built upon by new dwelling houses
and hockey lane runs to the the east
and the northeast
in terms of the detailing of the new
dwelling house chair this is the floor
plans and the elevational detailings
the
elevation to hockley lane is
this unit here it's referred to in the
report of the various other elevations
as we saw yesterday
sign visits
just for completeness chair this is the
scheme that had consent branded for it
for extensions ii main house
this is the the main house the white
with the extensions the stippled
elements added to it that has consensus
and as reported in the officer
report
and that's the floor
plans of the approved scheme for the
extensions
and then finally chair just a slide to
remind members of what we saw yesterday
on site visits this is the
property that would be demolished
and rebuilt and you can just see on this
slide the various elements of that which
have been removed in preparation for
the works that would have facilitated
initially the extensions but which have
subsequently led to the application for
you this afternoon
thank you chair
thank you
i believe we have one speaker this
afternoon
you'd like to take the seat and state
your name thank you
when you're ready you have three minutes
thank you chair uh good afternoon uh i'm
stephen jones from stancliff homes
uh thank you for allowing me the
opportunity to address the committee
this afternoon
the application before you seeks
planning approval to demolish hockey
house and build a new two-story house
with a double garage
for the point of doubt i can confirm
that it was the original intention of
stanclick homes to retain hockley house
and to that end we engaged architects
and engineers to produce a detailed
design to extend the building to form a
five-bedroom house with a double garage
plans were submitted to your authority
which received planning approval in
february twenty twenty one
preliminary works started in spring last
year which involved the demolition of
the rear two-story extension and a small
single-story outbuilding
we've also accomplished the construction
of the natural stone boundary screen
wall between hotly house and our hotly
rise development in accordance with the
approved plans for that development
during the preparatory works
we discovered that hockley house has no
foundations at all and is in fact built
straight off the clay subsoil just below
ground level
this has had a major impact on our plans
since the entire building needs
underpinning
to all the external and internal walls
to ensure its structural stability
and the cost of this is prohibitive
we're therefore seeking planet
commission to replace hotly house with a
new home
and submitted a planning application in
august 2021
which locates the new house largely on
the footprint of hockey house and
presents strong active frontages to both
hockey lane and hockley rise
the new home will be built in coarse to
natural stone with stone heads and sills
and will retain the existing boundary
wall for the full length of hockey lane
frontage using reclaimed stone material
i note that in a report to this
committee that the planning officer
confirms that hockley house is neither
listed within a conservation area or
scheduled as a heritage asset
and that the county archaeologist raises
no objections to our proposals
she also confirms that the proposal
accords with all your authority's
relevant planning
policies sancliffe homes has always
endeavoured to work professionally and
responsibly
and to engage with your officers in a
positive and constructive manner as
possible
we also aim to build our homes to a high
standard and take the responsibility for
everything that we do very seriously
we put a great deal of thought and
effort into the proposal before you 30
seconds remain and i can confirm that
should you resolve to a grant planning
commission it's our intention to
commence and complete the construction
of the new home without delay
i therefore respectfully request that
you support your office's recommendation
and grant planning approval for this
application thank you chair
thank you are there any questions
counselor earlier
could you use your microphone certainly
i'm not loud enough
could you tell us are you using all the
same uh stone from the building you
knocked down or you bring it from
somewhere else
it is a combination of the two um if you
have visited the property you'll see
that actually there's a mishmash of
materials there and so we have some
stone that's capable of being reused
but you may have also seen on site that
there are pallets of stone which we've
brought in which we've actually had
tinted so that it will match the color
of the existing stone
so it's a mixture of two
congratulations on the rest of the site
as well it looks fabulous thank you
councillor hall
thank you good afternoon uh
i'm not a builder but i am aware that
buildings have to have foundations so
what the question i was going to ask is
uh you've told us about
your proposals and things like that but
the current
state or standard of the building then i
guess uh as it is at the moment is
totally unsuitable for any um
uh use really is that correct we have to
provide a structural warranty with any
properties that we sell
and you're seeing that we have started
to strip around the side
and to be quite honest we were quite
taken back with what we found because
basically once we'd stripped the
surface off
there's the bottom of the walls and um
and so we would have to underpin the
whole building both internally and
externally in order for it to be
structurally acceptable
okay thank you
councillor foster
thank you chair uh thank you mr jones um
for that description um
with regards to the application you put
through in february which was uh which
was agreed
and went through
uh would you have not already at that
stage when you put those plans through
know that there were no foundations to
the existing building that's uh that's
my first i'll let you answer that first
no no we didn't um we had assumed that
the building would have had adequate
foundations
so it was it was only when we started to
remove the ground around the building in
readiness
for those works that we discovered that
there was nothing there
thank you and my second question is have
you not done a cost in now how much it
would cost to underpin and preserve that
building in its current state and use it
yeah
yes our quantitatives have done that
which
um which as i've said in my report
really renders it um not viable for us
to to do that
thank you i'm councillor foster's i'll
student the question i would have looked
at but that's fine um
as you know where i'm quite disappointed
i know it's not a listed building but it
is part of winger worth's history
and i know quite a lot of residents are
very upset that it's going to be
demolished
if this goes through
i am pleased to see that you're going to
try and use some of the original stone
in the building
but do you find it quite interesting
we've got quite a few properties of that
age across the district that all have no
foundations because that's how they were
built in that time i mean my daughter
for one's got 300 year old cottage
hasn't got any foundations it probably
outlived a lot of the new modern
buildings so i do find it interesting
that
you can't work around that but i could
understand the legal side of that as
well so i am disappointed that you know
we are where we are
and
have you considered the um ongoing
historic value to the building
that you could put back into the village
in what sounds church because it was
used as the gardener's cottage it's part
of the estate would you sort of put up
something to say what it was and it's
history
and we'd be happy for example to be an
accurate photographic record of the
building as it currently stands
and an acknowledgement that that was on
site
um
um for future record yeah that'd be
brilliant perhaps some form of display
on population because it could actually
go into the local library yes yeah
that'd be great thank you
are there any other questions
no okay
oh we got a proposer or seconder for
this councillor elliot
thank you a second
thank you
yeah just before you take the vote if if
i may ask if
the
the discussion you just had with mr
jones in regard to the recording of the
building would you like um anything
formally added into any decision to
approve the application share to that
effect such as we may otherwise put in
with regards to archaeology works it
would just require the record to be
taken and
launched with ourselves and then we
could pass it on to the necessary
library or whatever if you would wish if
you would wish that controlled through
the permission if not then of course
they proceed otherwise just
clarification of that chair for me
daddy councillor elliot we can't hear
you
must just be you alan
and i've just said alan for your benefit
then again uh i wondered whether we can
go down the route to get in a blue
plaque on it state what it used to be
i'm not entirely sure whether that's
doable but if we can that's fine
although other than that we'll follow
what the chair asked for and go down
that road
okay yep we'll go through that route if
that's okay with everybody
that will go through it
through the
offices
yup everybody happy we'll go for a roll
call then okay
thank you chair uh counselor and cliff
councillor cooper four councillor
elliott
councillor foster
four council hall abstain
council hancock four
council hearts on four
castle jones four
council liggett four councillor powell
councillor rouse
four and councillor rough four
eleven four zero against one abstention
chair that's carried thank you thank you
very much
okay we're going through this quite
nicely today um item seven planning
appeals i will now call on the planning
manager to explain our next report
there's very little to say in respect to
this chair because as members will have
seen there is
no reported
appeal decisions that came in at the
press of writing but we have had
some since then they will be reported in
february
but if there are any specific questions
on appeals at this point chair i'll have
to take
are there any questions for
adrian
no you've got off lightly again adrian
okay
section
106 item eight on the agenda
planning uh i'd like the planning
manager to explain this to us i suggest
that we let him run through it first and
then i'll open up the floor for
questions and discussion
over to you adrian thank you chad just
very briefly further to the
resolution of planning committee in
october 2021 this is the first of the
quarterly reports that members have
asked to receive on section 106
agreements as is customary
we've divided the
appendices into three and i
understand that there has been access
through allen to
a larger printed version or a electronic
version of appendix say so i'm grateful
thailand for organizing that
yes that's on members desks i think yeah
the appendix a chair does identify where
we receive monies and there is deadlines
for spending those and specifically with
regard to the
six red items there identified in
paragraph 1.5
and
i hope that gives members the comfort
that we are aware of those
need to be spent and we are i mean the
process of or have indeed in one case
allocated that money for spending in
accordance with the legal agreements
appendix 2 chair
further to discussions in october
brings up to date the position where
we've actually got outstanding monies
and we are chasing them and that does
provide
an update for members on where we are
with those various elements
and
appendix c chair is
outstanding
106 is where payments aren't yet due
however further to the meeting october
they have been followed up and hopefully
brought up to date i hope that's the
case anyway and
you'll see that various letters have
then been sent out seeking any payments
that are outstanding so i'm hoping that
is in accordance with
members wishes of october last year and
brings the matches up to date and
specifically in regard to monies that
we've received and where they need to be
spent and then in respect of
payments that are due and that have not
been received and where we are with
those and particularly what we've done
and subsequently
if there are any questions that chair
has ever happily
taken
thank you asian i've got a couple and
it's um obviously i'm looking at the
ones for winger worth
and i see on page 79 on number
73 hanging banks and it said the first
letter was sent in
june 21
and the other one is again opposite land
opposite pioneer house
first letter was sent in october 19 and
a chase letter was sent in june 21
have we had any update on that
not that i'm aware further to the report
checked i will um if i may i will hold
those up specifically and find out that
the position is most up-to-date and
right to you to give you an up-to-date
position on those if that's okay
i don't want it to slip so we're faced
with uh
any more issues thank you
are there any further questions council
cooper
thank you chair uh yeah adrian i i don't
probably expect an answer at this moment
but foxhall in pilsley
um you're aware there was an outstanding
issue there um
from a meeting we had last
february i believe
we've still not received
an answer to that question yet i know
richard was following it up but uh our
clerk at pilsner parish council now has
asked me to follow this up again so can
we get some clarity on that please
yes cheerful may come back to cancer
cooper the
um i've also been contacted by the
parish council chair and
i have
myself um tried to get in touch with the
developer to further the matter move it
forwards and i will
as time goes on over the next few days
i'm hoping and unfortunately i've not
been able to contact the developer yet i
will keep the relevant members who
attended that meeting in february
up-to-date
there's progress i hope is made
for the discussions that we had at that
meeting and subsequently
thank you
any other questions councillor foster
councillor liggett and then council of
hearts
uh thank you chair uh just a couple of
concerns one is the royal hotel
atkington
another is the ridgeway craft center uh
ridgeway
um
not that i need an update on the actual
works right now what i'm concerned about
here is that
on the royal hotel for example we've got
this is on page 75 at the bottom
final lectures uh sent and we've got
october
it's october last year and to be
referred for further action so we've got
no no update from october
um
obviously now we're a few months on from
that so that could really do with
updating the whole idea of this report
is that it's up to date so what that's
essentially saying to me is that
nothing's been done since then if
something has been done since then it
needs to be on this
report here uh or we can put nothing's
been done since the 27th of october
that's that one and it's much the same
for the ridgeway craft center
claimed to be issued in the county court
at 12th of uh august
that's the last update i've got there so
just uh
just a free to be updated thank you
chair
just uh briefly on that chair by my
apologies to uh fostering members in
respect to the royal hotel um i
will make sure that some data certainly
the next time the reports brought chair
but i wasn't really impressed that we
have made some progress with legal
colleagues on that but i will make sure
that's updated when we've uh when we
next report chair i mean respect of
ridgeway again and
currently that's with
colleagues in the council's legal
section chest so then if the clarity is
needed i'll make sure that's done for
the next quarterly report that we bring
to members
council foster
yeah uh thanks for that uh mr kirk and i
appreciate that
but to receive the report in another
quarter when it's already once october
and once august uh for myself that's i'm
not happy with that i'd be happy to
receive a report on anything like this
at the next uh planning meeting
obviously with the permission of the
chair
um
and
it's not like we're asking an awful lot
of work to be done this same report can
be printed out again
with those two and if there's any more
it could be updated so we could actually
have the updates on those two so it only
needs printing out again and adding to
the back of the next
uh next purpose for the next planning
meeting so it's not like we're asking a
huge amount of work it's just that we
know what's going on with those two
rather than all waiting for another
three months
uh you know
that's that's understood and just so i
could be clear what members would like
would would you just like the
um appendices next time or would you
like just the the report with the
appendices and necessary updates
okay
uh thank you chair uh
however you want to do it we need the
information the planning committee needs
the information we need to be able to
look at this i've uh i've said this
before previous meetings we need to be
able to pick this up and look at it at a
glance
uh some of this is very difficult if you
look at when these papers were sent out
these original papers the original
agenda uh 10th of january admittedly
that's on paper and only today i've
received this um
this blown up um
[Music]
version of it
um we need this information before
and however you want to present it we
need it in front of us so we can all
understand it and we can all ask
questions
rather than just asking for updates and
same thing over and over thank you chair
adrian can we have the updates
information of the updates for the next
meeting so they're not rolling over for
another three months
yes of course
today
we'll deal with next month
councillor liggett
yeah i'm going to agree with councillor
foster to be honest because it looks
like yet again the same
the wool pack which is the one i brought
up
uh querying why they'd only got to pay
1948 pounds a month and haven't paid
that it looks like it's still there
legal team proceed to secure payments
outstanding on the 9th of november
so i i can't understand why if one is
not coming forward
letters or
proceedings aren't going monthly rather
than letting letting things keep going
on like this
because
it's a little bit annoying
okay to say the least and you know it
and it also on this it also says half of
properties occupied they've all been
occupied for about two years
okay
um
these these matters are with my
colleagues in the contentious side i did
try to speak to them before uh before
this meeting however they are extremely
short stuff
at the moment and there was nobody i
could speak to to get a clarification as
to where we are with this
as adrian says we'll be able to provide
that to get that clarification for the
next next meeting and i'm sure there has
been progress it's just
not um not shown on these reports but
you you will be provided with the
information at the next meeting
counselor hall
but did you want it counselor hearts
uh yeah adrian uh it's just um
i i know it's a county issue really it's
the wind whistle farm developments uh
that's kind of put to grassmore
uh i'm just wondering why there's
contributions for the five bits trail
and both have been
returned to the developer
any
we can find out why that is
i wasn't aware that the monies had been
returned to the developer chair but i
with county council colleagues on that
as
members are aware in many of the
agreements
monies now is either paid directly to or
discussions take place directly with
county council producers out with the
control of the district council so i
will need to follow that up with county
council officers child homes i'm not
aware of that
particular happening or what the wise
and wherefores of that i will find out
from the county council why that's
actually taking place
are there any further questions i missed
anybody
no thank you
can i ask that if we are prepared to
accept the report as is
yep okay thank you yep okay i just need
to show of hands on this
jay
so
pleased to hear i have no matters of
urgency so move on to item 10 which is
the exclusion of public
public will be excluded from the meeting
during this discussion of the following
item of business to avoid the disclosure
to them or exempt information as defined
in paragraph three part one of schedule
12a to the local government act 1972
you